oh what is this like a little mini boss
oh it's got a health bar and everything
oh my goodness it just charged me and
took two of my bees
dude
harry doesn't dodge far enough
oh my goodness
i'm afraid when i turn around they're
gonna be like right there
no
oh my goodness he took so many beans
all right
oh my goodness dude
don't take away so many beans man
what i just walked into it
oh goodness they're chasing me
a lot more this time hey back you savage
all right all right all right ron hold
on buddy
oh jeez dude this thing is not playing
around hedwig
hedwig bringing me the pumpkin pasty
dude i can't believe how many birdy bop
beans we have lost
we're about to be back down to zero
okay 18.
[Music]
come on
what is with all the creatures taunting
you in this game man
whoa
window
see i told you man
oh my goodness
about to lose all the beans right here
in this room man am i not holding it
down long enough like is that is that
the problem
are you serious my health bar guys
are you serious
we've only lost
four beans so far
if i wasn't losing beans left and right
i would just stand there spamming
defendo
what
like lock on harry dude
got that one and then more just more
just come out they just just more spawn
did my beans reset please tell me my
beans reset
they don't reset dude uh whoa
oh that is so sneaky man i was just
gonna run through the door
then i was like you know what look
there's a chest right there
oh
no
oh that little punk i don't even care
about the beans dude imagine if he
knocked me completely off
go away
are you for real
just just grab the chest harry just grab
it
out of my way
okay wait wait wait wait wait a second
no i'm shooting him
what a punk
can i just like sneak by this guy yeah
see
that's what i was trying
we should have never tried to get 100
birdy bop beans guys
i think what you're gonna have to do is
basically like after
no no no wiggin well potion for
the win
no
that stream of fire goes so much further
than i expect it to go
all right
let's see i was ready for it that time
no
i thought it stopped when i blasted him
so wait what's the point of me what's
the point of me blasting him at all
we've lost so much health so many beans
we're gonna be we're gonna be down to
zero beans pretty soon
oh my goodness
i don't care i'm getting my beans back
i'm gonna shoot that one off to the side
all right all right
what it just didn't react
it didn't work i pressed the button
come on get that bean bag i want the
beans i want all the beans back give
them to me
oh my goodness it resets
i guess this whole hallway resets
on the birdie bop beans
how about this one this one reset yes it
did
we're already back up to 82.
i'm gonna run back up to hogwarts and
what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna try and
gather enough birdy bop beans i want to
hit 100 because that is how many i need
for the aloha mora spell so we'll see i
mean we'll hop in if we can yeah if we
can get something right here we might as
well go ahead and try
it's at three three more three more
are you serious
how about you
how about you
oh there it is
i was about to say dude if that
i thought that one was going to refuse
to give me just one more like they
intentionally make it harder the closer
you get to 10
or
110 what am i talking about i wish it
was just 10. sorry gotta collect a few
beans first
fields won't notice
it's all good it's all good we're okay
we're okay here
oh wait i think this is gonna lead me
dude i hit him come
on i think this puts me out right at the
top
like where gryffindor tower is oh i'm
stuck
dude i'm stuck i can't move
i really can't move the game's glitched
are you serious i just blast that one i
thought
[Music]
i'm running
dude they're not even close to me come
on
that is garbage
dude okay wait for it to pop back out
and
go on your merry way
no that's garbage that's totally garbage
you know what i'm gonna stop spending so
much time on the birdie bop beans
because
when you're really doing the missions
you unlock quite a few anyway
i knew he was gonna get me man
they don't stay stunned long enough like
i feel like it wears off really quickly
oh goodness the ghosts come out here too
oh look at that you like that dodge
all right both of those are open and
unlocked now ready to go
relax
is it straight ahead here we go
come on
it's not that far of a fall
it's really not that far
all right let's see if we can actually
fight these guys
nope can't do anything
so it's just like sorry you're gonna
take a hit right here
just didn't have enough range on that
one man
it's so annoying down the 40 birdie bob
beans
40 bertie bought every flavor beans
are you serious right now
we lost five beans
this is unfair completely unfair
[Music]
there we go
i knew it man i knew it i was just at a
bad angle
that was too close man are you serious
it still actually hit me oh now i'm
definitely dead
all right so now we're back in here of
course the ghosts are just
immediately attracted to us
now watch that one's gonna go after me
not give me any time to dodge
i told you dude i told you
that's so ridiculous
look look at that like what do you do
man what do you do there's no way to
dodge when i'm on the ledge like i feel
like things like that like that's poor
game design that's just poor game design
there's no defense for it like there's
no there's no way i can hide right there
how about birdie bot beans
we need we clearly need to replenish our
birdie bop beans now
oh we could go around and open up all
the student desks come on did any of you
leave like a chocolate frog behind
there's one birdie bob bean
that makes the whole the whole thing
worth it right there
[Music]
now see at least with the books like i'm
just being reckless right now
if i cast a spell on the books
that will stop them at least for a time
i should not be lingering guys i should
not be lingering
and it's all just for one bean there's
it's like completely such a waste of
time dude
doing all that for one bean when i'm
going to lose more by getting hit
actually the limited edition
oh limited edition what does that cost
30 30 bucks every limited edition birdie
bot
we gotta go with the limited edition
bertie bought number 69 1935 to present
inventor of bertie bought every flavor
beans
all right very
nice dude look at him just standing
there
wait what
i don't know why it didn't hit hit him
the first time it was weird oh he's
still there
what i don't understand
[Music]
oh that guy kind of appeared out of
nowhere you see that
[Music]
we're losing so many beans man we're
losing so many beans
[Music]
oh no oh no there's a lot in here
oh and that was a direct hit oh no harry
run
okay i don't think i can worry about the
beans in here man
we can't jump
that's just not even fair man
like you don't even have enough time to
dodge that
lock on to him
oh wow yeah i really want that bean
because that's what we're worried about
right now
i see right now it should let you run up
and
see this okay it does hurt if you run
into him i was curious like
do you even take damage at all yeah i
want those birdie bobby pins
if you'd like to see more of this play
through then check out the playlist on
the right side of your screen now which
is my full harry potter and the chamber
of secrets playthrough and i had an
absolute blast as always thank you all
so much for watching i'll talk to you
again soon